Tim here on the right Ron obviously
there's still a couple games left to go
but having been through most of this
tournament now and sort of seeing how
it's played out are there any things you
would like to see the league change
about it or tweak for it for next year
and
Beyond
um I don't know I haven't thought about
it um if I had some time to think about
I may have a better answer but haven't
really thought about it you know we've
just played the games you know when they
we've had games on Tuesdays and Fridays
we've we've played them um you know you
kind of know it's a tournament gam some
you kind of forget about it until you
get to the arena either at home or on a
road and you see the court so you know
it's a tournament game so um you know
but I haven't thought about if I would
have any changes um but I mean if it's
not broke don't fix it um and seems like
it's going really well and it it to your
point it seems like across the league
teams and players have sort of bought
into this maybe faster than the general
public might have expected have you sort
of felt like this has gotten more
momentum internally faster than maybe
you would have thought
um listen I
don't Adam Silver is a genius
so it's that simple so uh it's going to
work